il ne préfère
arrêter paraître passant finalement ils
vous disent pas facile entre autres ils
sont pas très drôle à tort tout à
l'heure bon je vais tout vous répondre
il y aurait quand même un goût terry est
ce que je peux répondre ainsi à ses
seins ces défections bon allez soro un
mot bon je dis
je dis que c'est ce que c'est qui ces
gens là n'ont rien à dire pourquoi t'es
les invite à sa part de tout le monde à
droite par les mêmes ceux qui n'ont rien
à dire pourquoi es tu as vite des
lycéens il ne veut rien dire je faisais
ça ne veut plus rien dire lycéens cdmr
de forêts vitraux du défunt bercy seront
à leur écoute excuse moi j'espère que
caméra et sur moi
polak je vous dire que ce que je viens
d'entendre dire là c'est rien du tout
c'est les moues de ma mère c'est des
mots de ma grand mère c'est des mots
imprimés qu'on leur a mis dans la tête
ils n'ont en rien dire ces jeunes eux
qu'on l'a et je vois moi d'y aller pas
de finale ils n'ont rien à [ __ ] bon 16
à nu fischer sainson ce sont des petits
than qu'on nourrit c'est très bien et
qui ferment leur gueule merci sort bien
alors écoutez je